we need William Jacques Attali charging
enough money on of putting a trigger
yeah yeah you know
you
yes no good welcome to our Monday Night
Live show let's get going do is on yeah
many funny duels coming I don't know I'm
going to request a five minute game and
see what happens
yeah I know also to all of you gain and
Chet started Grand Master will impass
who is old impose I don't know
axel Batman from Paraguay this person is
really high rated over the board I think
to six something and they're so in place
very reliable set up against my night a
three g3p and Cairo 97 now often played
or c6 as a wish for be 33 today I can
try to play especially cough but you net
don't know if it will happen so yeah I
think our tank or 93 this position I had
on the board really a lot over the years
playing 44 now huh and he immediately
attacks it now I have four only played
against him two times with the third 50%
score night C frame fear Queen d3 is is
coming here
quite annoying
maybe h3 I don't know I probably should
have prepared you for for one model
meat grinder wants to know what my
favorite line against the Ponciano is
that's a really rare line the point
Jonnie I think the d5 is good on will
free it's probably the best move but you
can also very reliably play really light
f6d 484 I'm sorry this is actually a
good choice in practical terms
I hope do you wanna ninety-four looks
shaky okay didn't play it so develop
here my ideal own scenario is to play
with f4 so my next move was very likely
Queenie - I just wonder you know
Queenie - and then go for FY 85 I think
I can probably do that next month in
fact I would have preferred to have the
a look on d1 but I couldn't do it at the
time still play it maybe I could have
prepared a little bit more but I don't
think it's a big deal if I can get in if
I here in such a position I have to do
it yeah hello to all of you in the chat
I don't think that my camera thinks that
the bulk tank is a legit opening I
really don't maybe you just want it to
be funny
okay so Knight to d6 I can take in 96 or
yeah I can actually do it it doesn't
really it's not a big deal so um that
looks like a nice position I just wonder
how to improve from here I can go before
prevent ninety-five
I don't think interesting
any four takes b5 is very powerful
I mean powerfulness may be the wrong
word it's very direct that's what I'm
trying to say let's do it didn't
calculate everything here but it looks
looks interesting
okay a five and then where is he going
on ITIF aid then also takes his six or
be six and then nine takes person
[Music]
- probably back to an ATM and now I can
take and go for the 55 or maybe I have
something better I don't see it though
just go Bishop d5 next and also I think
I'm also threatening route d5 simply
attacking the knight
you think we should defy the threat
hmm I don't know time 186 would be good
to play with
let me just block this first maybe just
look see one next I mean he is not
exactly it doesn't have many moves
available maybe even give fire I know it
blocks the diagonal
my knight f7 is still on it's a fork
maybe I had it earlier
and I didn't see it check check the line
coming reason allenge
Joe that didn't work I think I think I
could have played 9 c8 earlier ready
okay
anyway I won that game against
Grandmaster Bachman that's good
new game so um any questions that in the
chat had to really pay attention
how old is my oldest student Wow
it's a good question I think roughly
fifth roughly fifty years old and I'm
not wrong
shouldn't taught this crew that our a
lovely fifth started okay
a veteran rust yeah we had this guy in
earlier shows the veteran russian o
kings let's play this the funky f5 line
at least we get some some guaranteed
funny game let's say okay played d3
[Music]
so yeah is the 50 year old student
making any progress on I don't know yet
it's a he's very fresh I mean I we only
started very very recently okay I
changed the pawn structure trying to
make it for target can't we have to
trade that check
hmm five if I take this that opens up
his piece I can actually play a form
yeah that makes sense which techniques
books do you recommend as a question
it's well it depends I mean I don't
think you need it if you are not a
super-strong player you don't really
need a tactics book you can just use
tactics trainers online they are really
really good if you are already a master
level player you can think about some
more advanced books to to improve your
calculation skills I'm not talking about
like yeah stuff like maiden yeah quick
maids or motifs and so on but really
complicated positions then you might
want to use a book other than that just
just use online tactic trainers so he um
has moved the queen around quite a bit
and then wonder if I have something on
the Queen but I don't see it I just
wanted to have this square
[Music]
shame let's go to g3
maybe he wants to play a 6-under special
that's really that's possible
[Music]
rebooting this what tactics books stick
did I work with him yeah I've worked
with a couple it may use I did give away
the a seven corn because it feels
unimportant in the position I don't
really consider that a sacrifice and ok
so I have this check here just to check
or f33 looks pretty awful for what what
do I think what do I think about blue
bounds performs the dogma yeah it's not
it's not really a performance yet I just
one round can't rounds played yeah when
why shouldn't he be the veto session
again I mean he's very good
theoretically blue bomb and I think he
did a good job they're getting a great
opening position and then winning and I
think I winning here as well check be
weird if you can save this chick on do
we have something more even jack check
is pretty strong Queen g3 should do the
trick he's got this check though why it
should stowaway
check the dough look something
now look after when should win
threatening made on me to wind this one
now I don't know what chronic mr.
ganzfried oh say have good I don't know
what if he if he said it after the game
probably just a complete blackout fight
resigned
okay so I won that game against veteran
Ross game started h2o2 what is he up to
gage - OH - yep
I don't know I didn't want to I mean I
am porn I thought was totally irrelevant
in that position that I had with white
already being blasted on the under on
the kingside check yeah here I'm getting
the porn back but this is different
difficult difficult line for black to
play so let's see yeah that is not easy
to play I think I can actually here I
can work with the sacrifice of that porn
but it is stuff it is tough to play
night there twin g4 is also in the mix
here
preventing Queens u4m yep my bishop
doesn't have many squares but maybe I
can do this
left make sense and wants to open this
up and if I take b5 that's not really
great development
okay tix I can take with the rope here
it's not terrible I think not happy with
this position but what can you do not
much no I won't play the bong cloud it
even after crossing 2500 I wouldn't do
that
it's just a little bit too too awful
okay
95 is what he wants to do yeah yeah
probably put this here look at the a4
porn
yeah d5 is to lose here
how do I play this who the bishop I
wonder about the bishop to have six this
is an idea and I'm not sure but his
bishop looks strong
I think the bong cloud opening is a fine
then kingi to ever not wrong I really
don't know why this gained some
popularity on reddit it is just like
complete nonsense
okay yeah this I wasn't sure a lot okay
yeah maybe maybe this is exactly a good
structure for him I mean no it is a good
structure for him I just wasn't sure now
you can try to use this diagonal and
with the group here okay okay try and
solve it it feels a little bit
unrealistic he wants to double
so let's well played by white
[Music]
entirely sure what is ideas
yeah that's a really really big hole
bill of some counterplay and that's okay
I can try to get there with the now
doesn't draw really nicely played here
my white
yeah I wanted to check on h2 what
currently d7 is hanging and I had to
cover it first
yeah I wondered about that not sure I
mean bye-bye position still lacking some
time more elimination but I don't know
it's not so bad to keep that for the
moment
Wow
poor young really nicely played by white
almost no hope here
yeah I sees everything great absolutely
great them now it takes and so on take
screen BH able to take my queen
at least I've set your problem
how does he do it now Queen d2 she goes
to g1 I've queen a2 and I'm actually
catching upon but not all that easy
I've defended this in mouse whip
check check check check
black for fits on time at the end got a
winning position evening all of this but
yeah you played very well
the been game fell apart it okay anyway
let's get to new game eeeh games would
push a 2010 2010 yo okay okay yeah this
is a somewhat odd move order to go to
the Leningrad think I'm not sure that
this is so great for micro scene
there's a question in the chat hum
reminds the scheme for name to which you
can live which means if I read my system
bindings which yes I did check it's been
a while though so I've got I think I've
gotten a pretty nice position here the
e6 pawn can that be all that grade I
don't think so but how do I pressurize
it clean here Bishop c4 maybe only one I
can start with rook e1 that feels right
I should leave the queen there maybe
this is also good and tending 95 the
right mode yeah so this is for Bishop d3
I don't think virus are white sir that
reading my system will help you at your
current playing level I don't think so
it actually has some good things for for
beginners but basically everything that
is on a higher level is hopelessly
outdated by now so you don't really need
it ok um what is going on here he's not
I just wonder if I have something more
indecisive then group g1 which is good
of course let's do it now let's be
practical and then push the Queen back
next structure is so terrible that this
is totally fine
by the way if somebody in the chat was
coming from Poland
is anybody there from Poland I think it
wasn't Gattaca jeans go around he was
from Poland I think I'm asking because
I'm thinking about playing again in
Poland
okay so this is okay but how do I get
more pressure here I was thinking about
this move Bishop to d3 and then put some
pressure on d6 both d6 and e6 looks weak
hi I got jet skis around yeah I'm
thinking about playing playing again a
tournament it's a it's a tournament in
in Cracow and it is some right after
Christmas this is something that I'm
thinking about you probably know Krakow
then right it's supposed to be really
beautiful city which yeah makes me
consider playing in the tournament also
it is this time right after Christmas I
usually don't have that many lessons
anyway so it's something that would make
sense get to get get some vacation and
and so on yeah yeah I'm just increasing
the pressure yeah
kako mm-hmm so the difficulty meter I
should probably pronounce it differently
like it's probably some more polish way
to pronounce it and I'm doing it more in
a German way okay if I take I give them
some squares I don't want that so let's
go here now it's an open tournament it's
an open tournament it's a really nice
one I think it sounds extremely nice
because also they they have
ABC group and da group is above yellow
2,100 that's pretty nice
so you don't if you are like on my level
you don't get any not a single player
was really low rated threatening 95 here
okay I think I just keep the rope here
and then put more pressure later it's a
really a pretty pretty substantial open
tournament it looks pretty good so how
to do it Jim I would like to made of
course playful made my queen doesn't
have many squares and night before
sometimes
let's do it yet creature 8 is not the
best move in this position which I know
but it's I'm so better and it's a bit
more practical when thinking for ages
not finding a maid and then losing and I
don't know I have not yet decided to to
go but it's a ton I found that yesterday
in the calendar and it would fit really
well I usually would would actually go
by by train I'm not I don't like to fly
and the train connection is it is a long
run so normal treble but I've already
been to client my name by train and it
was totally ok Marcus if you consider to
play it's not far from your place check
of course your Krakow is an airport this
is the city as seven have some 700,000
people here it's it's a it's a really
it's a second biggest city in Poland
right after war so no come on really
come on this is sick after this game
really come on here yes language look h5
rook h5 like every move wins of course
no look h5
my god I also think I said the exchange
and wind looking at porn ending yeah
anyway and the tournament it's it's it's
I think it's from 27th of December till
May as May till January 4th
Nana through age six or whatever
everything wins of course not Luke age
five though that doesn't win yeah after
you need to do this kind of thing to
goose okay they have a new request sound
but not yet paired
I have not been to Krakow no I've been
to rot Slav Breslau which was really
nice it was really nice trade so I've
got a real game request out but not get
paired wow there's some no game started
start to something is it just do
something
the London crazy really crazy often you
get that
you might see the German word that's not
translatable to English wow that's a
really good question but I don't know I
don't really know it's a really good
question though I would need to think
about it I think to give you a really
good answer ok I'm changing the pawn
structure here hoping that b3 doesn't
work well here it is pieces currently
don't don't feel right walking beside
play which writes normally this is what
white normally does okay oh I shouldn't
have gone back what what is stupid idea
I was a stupid idea
Standish is a German word yarnís - it's
probably not easily translatable how do
you what do you how do you Canada for
now yet super swung is a cool word but
it is actually everything is German but
it's something that it is understandable
English so I'm taking stuff even though
I wonder he gets that but not sure if
this helps them so much
we are tween 86 just to keep them away
hey Rocco is 12 hours by train from your
place Marcos no I don't think so this is
actually tricky we can talk about that
if you hit it's trickier the train ride
is long I mean I've been to Breslau and
rock flock and it takes ages but it's so
it's still quite fun to do not good not
not good disposition
it's got night before as well this one I
didn't think about annoying
let's trade our schadenfreude a yes
that's a really really cool German word
out you're completely right
that has no direct translation Bishop c5
respond you move maybe I'm happy that
I'm still alive in this position after
over look at tons of moves
yeah you have to check the train
connection are found swickle can be
really tricky because they may be 95 cm
can be really tricky because there might
be some connection by a girl it's that
they don't show that really tricky
anyway I hope I didn't check this
calculate this tactic but it looks it
seems okay
so I'm a pawn up and I can try to play
on the dark squares I just wonder how
exactly he's weakening the dark squares
anymore what's that night to h5 coming
yogi would be five rook is 5 and night
h5 also on the course okay Queen f2
would blunder they will clear I
shouldn't do that
this one
threatening 93 maybe g4 he has to play
with that doesn't look very healthy even
though I might not be am a fatigue or
take bishop takes I can go Queen d3 yeah
check and then you hope the Queen though
right
going to be aid can check here in 94 as
well check uh no time check
maybe I shouldn't have done that because
of the time situation check it is
winning this ending but that's actually
not time money to win it's not super
easy to win
check check check
come round you with the king yep tank
should do the trick
keeping all the pawns I can push the
import check no check
I'm same idea resign
okay I don't know if I would we'll play
the computer in the near future on one
of my videos it's extremist radar okay
I'm wide against my Moscow Grandmaster a
monster with that key ones Hudson aw
okay so okay it doesn't play the Kings
engine it's actually normal trademark of
Turkish players they really play the
Kings Indian a lot
this guy doesn't
so sorry I'm going to fly in my office
it's probably just equal
it goes back okay so we decided to
rather beacon the pawn structure it's
not a big deal admittedly okay so he
wants to play before and probably go
manage I would say Mary can go to before
night a3 what's the deal I don't know
Queen d7 is that what he wants to do
I can actually take me five you yeah now
I need to trade the bishop I just wonder
Queen 92 or yeah yes so I could I could
take them okay his idea is to play
Bishop to e7 but it doesn't work right
I've got that covered
so who do I play
[Music]
maybe e5 is what he wants to do yeah
let's just prevented
so I would like to get the rukon to the
a file of course not easy I mean here
play can play okay one but I have 92
then I can return here
look at five specialty aid could try to
bring play Bishop dat 76 repealing this
thing no I don't know I really have a
threat here
boys coefficient the eight coming
don't think so I don't think I have much
here to be honest it is pretty please
solid for lucky my position is more
active but I don't really have much
yep let me come with that
we should be six
I wonder half maybe I'm actually
trapping my rook here probably not I
have 95 in some cases just wondering if
you move so look let night be a you know
I use a Logitech c920 you're so welcome
I'm not that happy actually with the
with the picture depends sometimes it's
okay what does I really feel it looks
like crap okay so what are you doing
here
try to traitors I'm not happy with the
light in my office the green screen
oftentimes looks weird
it's tough to Quinby seven maybe
[Music]
maybe just Queen c7 is okay
95 and then what is going back am if I
take the take this Queen it to time
warning quite remarkable so and
fortunately I didn't really pay
attention with the time because I am a
bit down on time here
which is
so probably equal is ending don't know
we can do much down no b3 I can actually
go to a five which is weird her piece
I'm sorry my voice is failing me
yeah I have no time mr. problem I don't
know the position might be okay but it's
a bit tough to figure it out when you I
know we have met with me that's it I was
to settle the whole game and I didn't
didn't play it well check check check
No ah crap sorry
check game drawn okay
yeah yeah yeah where was the net I
didn't I mean there was a must have been
some position where chances I don't
believe it at all with the British
changer that started okay one more game
against em Western I don't really know
how protect to give you your pestering
viruses frickin London and it's really
so awful amazing
it's really amazing check-check
I think I've had this on the board on
numerous occasions and why just ask
absolutely nothing the main problem is
actually something that you can afford
sleep here because you think okay
nothing is ever going to happen and then
you play some nonsense yeah watch out
for the bed Benoni I don't think this is
a bad belly I'm snatching material I
don't believe this for white at all keep
you 5 under control
what did Western do with is raiding him
really screwed up this rating
it's going to place you for okay now I
can actually play this because the night
is away from the d4 square
maybe he intends to play Queen to g4
it's possible No
okay so he wants to go and for something
so let's see can I now finally finally
get to see free well I have played so
many weird moves oh not good didn't see
that one coming
look before on the side
so we had moved but maybe it's not bad
takes rook takes his e4 pawn this could
I take on c3 I have no idea I'm I have
no idea I'm just too bad if I take with
the deep hole I have 96 actually yeah
let's cover this I mean he has to look
out for all kinds of stuff c3 and and
everything and a3 yeah now he wants to
take with the bishop I guess jump to see
free again
I accept his yes to watch out for all
these things it's not so easy
yeah f5 is probably what I need to do at
dead end and at the end it's not so easy
to do could be could be wrong now I
don't really watch much streamers or
anything not because they are bad or
anything it's just that I don't just
don't have time don't have time there
make good things of course what I do
watch like to watch us stuff like when
they when they do live broadcasts for
rapid and blitz especially tackler grand
chess to events in Paris and Louisville
this is stuff that I really like to
watch it's a it's really excellent both
excellent entertainment and it's also
interesting for the chest yeah in the
meantime I think I think I'm on a way
jet to to something good
they actually managed to win the c3 pawn
at the end which indeed was questionable
if I ever ever managed okay so that's an
interesting move I want to I want to
actually check me this is this guy this
is possible 92 there's no clear made
there should be some kind of need it's
going to check there I don't see a maid
which is kind of strange really hook f1
maybe for more fun let's do it for 92
check I've got to check their time
warning I was stupid
didn't see the check on e3 okay then I
have to do it differently yeah we had
this perform okay now is Luke is some
somehow into the game again which is not
good
maybe Knight to f4 was right before
this don't quite don't quite get it
this position I think threatening made
down and on h3 I had to add to draw
already so how'd you see it cover age
three here this is interesting
Queen Q 1 and down long time here no
and down on time this is probably wrong
because of the time but I didn't see a
move really this is crazy getting such a
position here from a Kentucky winning
position I mean not not even not even
close - so okay at least the position is
a draw check
game drawn huh now I scooped it up I
really screwed this off we have some
some way of taking a four it's not what
you want to do I think I missed this
idea here this is something that I want
to check with clay okay
I missed a Miss debt probably no I can't
any takes be five let me place this move
somehow so how do I win this there must
be a winning disposition I cannot
believe there isn't the engine shows
this move and they not so easy okay I
hope you enjoy the string I'll be back
next week next Monday yeah I guess
that's it I hope you enjoyed it it was a
up and down affair but many entertaining
games I hope thanks for watching I'll be
back next week